jetzt kommen wir wieder zu was
haptischen nämlich zum Geld und das
gehört zu unserem großen Thema
Digitalisierung dazu Frau neige das ist
ihr großes Thema denn sie wünschen sich
das weiterhin Bargeld in unseren Taschen
ist das nicht alles digitalisiert wird
ist es gibt jetzt Pläne die
Innenministerin hat das gesagt eine
Obergrenze von 10000 € bei ihnen gehen
ein bisschen die Alarmglocken los sie
fürchten langfristig könnte es so kommen
dass wir alle nur noch ohne Bargeld
bezahlen müssen das ist zumindest der
langfristig geplant das habe ich
zumindest in den Reden gehört bei dem G7
Gipfel und dann gab es auch eine
hochrangige Konferenz am 7 November in
Brüssel in der es auch erwähnt wurde
dass man dahin steuern möchte ich möchte
eine kleine Geschichte erzählen ich war
am Flughafen in Frankfurt und wollte
ganz normal meinen Koffer einchecken und
der hatte da war zu schwer also da
musste noch etwas bezahlt werden ich
wollte bar bezahlen
und die Lufthansa wollte es nicht
annehmen und dann sagte man mir frech
ins Gesicht das ist ein bargeldloser
Flughafen
wie gesagt es geht gar nicht weil das
ist ein gesetzliches Zahlungsmittel ich
bin nebenbei dann noch zur Bäckerei
wollte eine apfelecke essen also für
1,50 € oder so und die sagten das ist
ein bargeldloser Flughafen daraufhin
habe ich mich beschwert beim Finden beim
Aufsichtsrat des Flughafens das ist
nämlich dafür das ist der Minister das
für Finanzen in Hessen der mir sagt es
sind gesetzliches also dieses
gesetzliche Mittel ist Banknoten und
Münzen und die müssen die tatsächlich
nehmen also das gibt diese Tests das hat
ja mal Jean-Claude Juncker auch gesagt
wir probieren es aus und dann gucken wir
wie weit wir kommen und dann probiert
man es halt in so einem hektischen
flughaften und wenn man dadurch kommt
dann macht man das
bei der Rundfunkgebühren
bar zu bezahlen es wird nicht genommen
das ist eigentlich ein kleiner Gesetzes
tatsache ist wenn ich nach China schaue
und schaue mir diese social
völlig egal
eu-parlamentar Kreis Christian teres der
hat gesagt in einer Diktatur weiß der
Staat alles über den Bürger in einer
Demokratie weiß der Bürger alles über
den Staat und ich möchte eher die
Demokratie das heißt ich möchte kein
gläserner Mensch sein und ich möchte
auch bar zahlen können und nach Artikel
128 des
aeuv-vertrags ist nämlich der
Unionsvertrag gibt es nur ein geltendes
gesetzliches Zahlungsmittel und es sind
Banknoten und Münzen dann gibt es noch
das Kreditgeld also dass man aus nichts
schöpft und dann gibt's noch das
kreditbankengeld dass man intern
verwendet um die Seiten auszugleichen
digitale Euro stehen da nicht drin das
bedeutet man verstößt sogar gegen
Unionsrecht wenn man jetzt den digitalen
Euro einführt ohne alle Staaten
einstimmig abschließen zu lassen oder
abstimmen zu lassen ob sie den Vertrag
ändern würden weil die können das gar
nicht einführen ohne den Vertrag zu
ändern diesen Paragraph oder diesen
Artikel 128 sie haben schon gegen ganz
andere Sachen dabei
500 und 1000 Euro weil ich gut da ist
man für alle Eventualität genau also ich
habe auch daheim immer Bargeld weil es
einfach für mich Situationen gibt wo ich
brauche und ich bin auch jemand der
immer wieder dran denkt
keine Ahnung Blackout wird ja jetzt auch
angekündigt kann in Städten passieren
oder wir haben zum Beispiel verbrennen
mehr da kommt ja niemand mehr an den
Bankautomat du kannst nirgends mehr Geld
abheben und ich lasse mich nicht darauf
ein dass ich meine Daten meine
persönlichen Daten sogar eine Bäckerei
am Flughafen in Frankfurt abgeben das
funktioniert nicht und ich rufe wirklich
alle Bürger auf sich dagegen auch zu
werden weil dieser Weg die Menschen
daran zu gewöhnen Ihnen die Freiheiten
abzugewöhnen ist ein falscher Weg der
geht in eine Form der Überwachung des
Überwachungsstaates es ist schon
passiert ich weiß ich versuche deine
Geld Überweisung zu machen und die
Postbeamten bestand darauf dass ich den
Zweck angebe
Finanzierung eines Bordells
hat das gemacht
ich hätte auch schreiben können Spende
für den naschen Untergang der
Europäischen Union wäre auch okay
ja und wenn sie ist mit einer
eingespülten Bürokratie zu tun haben die
allerdings ihre beste Zeit vor 45
bereits hinter sich hat dann haben sie
ständig solche Absurditäten und sie sind
schon ein gläserner Mensch ich auch aber
noch weiter möchte ich es nicht ziehen
lassen und ich gehe zum Beispiel nur
wenn ich einkaufen gehe immer bar ich
zahl immer bar sie haben keine
Kreditkarten natürlich habe ich aber ich
zahl trotzdem mal das ist für mich der
reine das ist eine reine Notsituation
zum Beispiel auch im Ausland aber ich
halte mich da ich bin der konservativ
Bares es ist wahres ich zahle immer war
dann weiß ich auch was ich auf der Hand
habe ich habe auch so angefangen zu
arbeiten ich habe mein Geld für meine
Arbeit immer bar auf die Hand gekriegt
und deswegen weiß ich auch mit Geld
umzugehen für mich ist das
wichtigste die verlieren den Kontrolle
Karte zahlen genau darauf an und 1828
zahle ist ja nur Karten Geld die Gefahr
die wir in China sehen dass die Leute
plötzlich ihre Kunden gesperrt kriegen
die die müssen praktisch ein Handy
besitzen damit sie überhaupt an der
Gesellschaft teilnehmen ich meine wer
erzählt mir denn dass ich ein Handy
haben muss damit ich durch in den
Restaurant gehen kann
schon mal verabreden für den Tag da die
Bankautomaten nicht funktionieren sie
stellen morgen treffen ja
Tankstelle
aber jetzt mal Spaß beiseite warum redet
man in der Bundesregierung darüber diese
10.000 € Obergrenze schaffen darüber
redet das ist der einzige Grund also
selbst sie sehen darin keine anderen
sind folgen und das neue
Geldwäschegesetz das Gesetz und sind
Vorschläge jetzt da die 10.000 ist ja
noch eine schöne Summe nicht da andere
reden von 2000 Euro
5000 runter die Italiener haben jetzt
gerade von 2000 auf 10000 erhöht oder
auf 12000 sogar weiß ich nicht genau
aber die sind jetzt wieder hochgegangen
witzigerweise
eingeführt nein haben sie nicht
sagen
aber sie wissen doch dass wir Liberalen
jetzt nicht für gegen das Bargeld
wenn die EU das beschließt das zu machen
dann müssen wir es als Landes müssen wir
es im Land umsetzen das ist so
anschließen können weil der Artikel 128
ist eine Startseite
das gleiche galt für die Übernahme
kollektiver Schulden es gibt kaum ein
Gesetz gegen das die EU Länder noch
nicht verstoßen haben und das wird
gelassen
kommt oder nicht wie positionieren Sie
sich dazu wir haben gerade über
Digitalisierung ähm also wir wollen das
Bargeld weiter haben logischerweise
keine Obergrenze nein wir werden
gar nicht genau
die Innenministerin möchte auf 5000
runter so wie es verstanden habe Frau
Feser ja das ist richtig
das müssen wir jetzt mit genau wie immer
da müssen wir uns jetzt halt streiten
aber da könnte ich jetzt so eine
Strichliste machen Moment also Atom hat
mir Bürgergeld und jetzt haben wir auch
noch Bargeld Obergrenzen mit der
Innenministerin nicht ganz feiner wird
die krötenliste lang größer das ist so
ja und die Frau immer wieder also das
ist schon okay
europäisches Geldwäschegesetz können wir
nichts machen tatsächlich
machen
gesetzliche gesetzliche Regelungen
durchsetzen die Geldwäsche erstmal
unmöglich machen
genau
am Ende ihrer Karriere war bevor sie
wieder von der EU zum Leben erweckt
wurde ich weiß gehört dazu aber trotzdem
wissen sie der 500-Euro-Schein wurde
abgeschafft es wird immer alles mit
Geldwäsche begründet
nein er wird nicht mal angenommen
das stimmt nicht doch nein das kann der
Dienstanbieter selber entscheiden
von Freiheit ist und so das stimmt ja
alles aber bargeld ist natürlich auch
macht natürlich auch eine Menge Arbeit
für den Einzelhandel ja ja
und wenn sie und wenn und wenn sie sagen
dass immer weniger Leute Bargeld nehmen
das stimmt das ja nicht die das also
trotz der Arbeit die die mit dem Bargeld
haben trotz der offenen trotz der sich
auf die armen naja die machen sie es
immer noch
dass man das verhindern
sie mit vielen anderen Sachen ja
immer wieder auftaucht an falscher
Stelle Generalverdacht genau
wenn ich auf die Straße gehe müsste ich
zum nächsten Bezirksbeauftragten und
Nachweisen sich keine Waffe bei mir habe
was den Generalverdacht ich könnte eine
Waffe bei mir haben und genau das was
deswegen ist dieses Gesetz
wenn Sie ein Auto
würde ich sagen wenn sie gebraucht
wahrscheinlich wenn sie Gebrauchtwagen
kaufen das ist wirklich das häufig so
man wirklich viel Geld Wechsel darf man
natürlich immer Bargeld dabei wenn man
irgendwo an einem Gebrauchtwagenhändler
daran kommt
ja auch mal akzeptieren dass das eine
Situation wo man Bargeld auf jeden Fall
braucht und auch viel wahre Geld da war
ich wahrscheinlich auch 10
Gebrauchtwagen nein habe ich gegessen
[Gelächter]
mit clankriminalität wird jetzt gerade
argumentiert es gibt ja immer
irgendeinen Grund im allgemeinen ja gut
aber es wurde ganz konkret abgegeben
das Problem das ist hausgemacht also die
clancreme Realität dafür muss ich nicht
auf mein Bargeld verzichten sorry das
ist nicht unser Thema dann müssen halt
die Politiker dafür sorgen dass diese
Parallelgesellschaften so nicht
existieren tut mir leid ja da kann der
Bund auch relativ wenig tun leider
natürlich
die Kompetenzen tun
aber nein
er sollte sich in die Freiheit halten
das steht ja sogar im Parteien gut
wirklich an die Frage also wir lassen
das Thema der Klang verliert weil das
ist natürlich zuständig die jeweilige
Polizei vor Ort auch der
Innenminister vor Ort und sie wissen
dass wir die klangkriminalität wenn wir
überhaupt über das reden wollen
Konzentration haben in Berlin wir haben
Konzentration in Bremen und wir haben
Konzentration im Ruhrgebiet das sind die
sozialdemokratischen Sinne das ist
dieser eine Familie die sich da überall
ausgebreitet hat und da gibt es
Statistiken zu aber das tatsächlich
Ländersache das ist eben nicht
Bundessache das ist das Problem
machen wollen wir das Grundgesetz ändern
und den Föderalismus aufgeben man sollte
vielleicht Artikel 128a EUV einfach
akzeptieren und nicht an Anfang
zu reden okay wir machen reden